we have some new developments on the  covid front tonight the health district  confirming the first three cases of the  brazilian covid 19 variant  also known as p1 health officials say  those are with clark county residents  the cases include a man in his 20s who's  reported to have one vaccine dose  the other two cases are a man in his 40s  and one  in his 30s both have not been vaccinated  now brian the brazilian variant has been  detected in several states and is  classified as a variant of concern by  the cdc  now this variant is thought to be more  easily transmissible  the health district is reminding  everyone to be vigilant about preventing  the spread of the virus wear a mask in  public get tested get the vaccine  and stay home if you're sick